在爬這個高尾山的時候。
影面也經常會遇到一些同樣在上山或下山的日本人。
他們真的身上就不論是妹妹還是爺爺經常掛。
我那個時候我一點都不覺得我身上的M6香了。
戴了最好的鏡頭
你戴了最好的相機。
去了一個最美的風景。
那一定會有一個完美的照片。
我相信大多數人一定是和我們一樣。
都在這個思維上上過這個檔。
總之真的就是你戴了兩台特別好的相機。
但是沒有一張好的照片留下來。
無論你是看了多少。
勸你戴什麼相機怎麼用相機的建議。
還是你看了那些很專業的旅拍博主。
在這些旅遊目的地產出的精緻美麗的照片。
其實那都是一種屬於這個時代的幻想。
一種信息留下內卷的產物。
Hello 大家好。
歡迎來到這期的懷讀寫真集。
我是海盧
我是靜雅
那麼今天我們想給大家帶來一期閒聊相機的節目。
對 因為最近天氣變好了。
相信大家也開始計劃自己的出遊。
然後我們最近也有一些新的。
已經計劃好的出遊的行程。
到時候可以和大家分享。
所以呢就想以此為由頭吧？
然後回歸一個久違的。
且大家非常感興趣的相機的話題。
就是出去玩戴些什麼相機比較好。
在出去玩的時候戴一台正確的相機。
是一定可以很好的改善大家出去遊玩的整個體驗的。
更不用說是在遊玩中的拍攝體驗。
我覺得首先這要從遊玩時候的心理開始說起。
其實大多數時候我們出遊。
無論是週末的短途旅行。
或者就是進城逛一逛。
還是到了長假小長假的時候。
去另外一個城市甚至到國外去玩。
這些所有的出行計劃。
我們大多數時候是為了放鬆。
是為了去換一個心情。
去看看不一樣的風景。
對，但實際上呢？
當我們在策劃自己的旅行的時候。
一想到這個戴什麼相機。
反而會讓自己覺得挺有壓力的。
而且就是確實實操下來。
我們很有可能就戴錯了相機。
朋友們聽到這裡會覺得很疑惑。
就是戴錯了相機
究竟多錯能算錯呢？
戴錯了相機會有什麼樣糟糕的後果呢？
這麼聽起來可能有點抽象。
我們真的是有非常多的血和淚的經歷。
可以去講給大家聽。
戴錯了相機
究竟是能把一場旅行給減分到什麼程度。
那我覺得可能很多朋友。
之所以會戴錯了相機。
都是因為非常重視這一次旅行。
我覺得就是關於出去玩戴相機這件事。
主要就會出現兩個大的方向。
一是說我是為了出去拍照。
而選擇了一個地方順便玩一玩。
我的主要目的是拍照。
還是說我的主要目的其實是旅行拍照。
或者說攝影
它是處於比較次要的位置的。
首先我們可能要認清這兩個方向的心理的取向吧？
這個其實在我們策劃出遊戴相機之前。
是應該想清楚的
這個問題其實要獲得正確答案也很簡單。
我覺得大多數幾乎所有的朋友。
肯定都能很快得出一個結論。
就是說真正只為了拍照拍出好看照片。
而安排一場旅行的人一定是非常少的。
他們一定是一群非常專業的人。
他們甚至要靠這種旅拍獲得的這些影像為生。
那他才可能去把拍照放到旅行前面。
大多數的人
我們都有自己的日常生活旅行是一種難得的條件。
那這個時候拍照其實是一個需要比旅行往後拍一拍的事情。
但恰恰問題就出在這裡。
因為我們出去玩的機會比較珍貴。
所以每當旅遊這個事情越來越臨近的時候。
我們就會更加的期望。
以萬全的準備把拍照這個事情準備好。
以此獲得一個特別好的回憶。
得一些特別好的照片來紀念自己這次難得的旅行。
對我覺得你剛才說到確實大多數人肯定出去玩。
他就是為了出去玩。
包括我自己也是
雖然我很喜歡拍照。
我雖然也很多次希望在旅行中甚至能拍出作品。
所以其實對於我自己來講。
我也經常會搞混
會模糊攝影和旅行的界線。
你知道嗎
那我覺得說到搞混這裡。
可以給大家簡單的說明一下。
具體可能是怎麼搞混的。
就比如大多數朋友想出去玩一下順便拍照。
那這個時候
因為大家平時不經常拍照。
或者說很重視這次旅行想拍的特別好。
所以就會去找很多的參考。
或者說專業攝影師的建議說。
我這個旅行到底帶什麼相機合適。
這個答案是不是可以抄一下。
我抄了一個作業
就能讓我的這個旅行變得更完美。
但恰恰這種心態有時候就把大家往坑裡去帶了。
因為有時候我們過度準備了相機和拍照相關的事情。
就會導致我們的旅行體驗開始有所下降。
對你說到這個時候我就想起。
最近總在小公書上刷到會有朋友提問說。
我春天徒步我應該帶什麼相機。
然後下面就會有那種特別專業的大哥。
就一看他真的就是非常厲害的攝影師。
裝備非常齊全
就給他講說你要用這個背包。
然後這塊要放一個快拆。
一般都是比較重型的這種相機。
他掛在這個背包袋上。
然後你就反正很像一個特種兵的感覺。
其實我每次看到這種推薦。
因為我其實也很想多看一些推薦。
但我看了這種推薦的時候。
我就覺得還挺有壓力的。
就彷彿說如果你要去登山。
你就必須要給我穿上全套的十足鳥。
或者什麼Mount Baylor。
反正就是要非常專業的設備。
但其實大多數時間。
可能我並不是那種非常高端的玩家。
這種或者說特別明確的特別顯勁的。
徒步的狀態
我可能就是去家附近的一個幾百米的小山。
去走一走
順手去拍一拍
但是可能比如說我們從社交網絡上。
所獲得的這些信息。
它就會給我一個超級專業。
超級頂級
非常完美的
什麼一個類似標達的一個東西。
但反而這個標達會讓我覺得非常有壓力。
且如果我想完成它的話。
其實還挺辛苦
也挺麻煩的
另外一方面其實就是。
哪怕像我們作為職業一點的攝影師。
也會偶爾的被界線模糊所搞亂了節奏。
說到這裡
我覺得我們要先來給大家。
好好地分享一下
我們之前帶錯相機的失敗經歷。
以及說失敗的相機選擇。
究竟是怎麼影響了我們的旅行。
對
我覺得大家應該也會聽我帶入感的。
我就先來講一下我的一個非常失敗的經歷。
有一次去意大利的時候。
那時候是我和敬雅的。
結婚一周年的紀念旅行。
這個時候肯定是一個很休閒。
然後放鬆的場景
但是我為了說
這不僅是個週年紀念。
還是個遠途的出國旅行。
然後我們還策劃了一條小眾的自駕遊線路。
去一些當時還不太火的景點。
我一定要用各種相機。
把中間的好風景
以及我們的記憶都留存下來。
同時我也要展現出。
我作為比較專業一點的攝影師。
一個攝影發燒友的水平。
我要拍出一個特別棒的照片。
我要用比較好的相機。
我要認真對待它
這個時候我就帶了膠片和數碼。
數碼我是帶了索尼的一套全畫幅。
可能兩鏡頭
然後膠片我也是帶了那種專業一點的自動機身。
就比如加能的EOS系列。
還是比較重一點的。
這個時候大家可能聽到這就感覺到了。
我真的是帶相機帶挺好。
而且挺認真的
但是在旅行的過程中。
其實問題就開始顯現出來了。
因為即使是有一些時間是在自駕遊的。
但是意大利這個地方。
它的城鎮街道是特別好逛的。
也特別漂亮
人走在這裡你都給背著相機。
背著相機這是一個很痛苦的事。
而且意大利對我來說是一個特別陌生的場景。
很多新鮮的畫面在刺激著我的大腦。
但是我拍照的時候。
我帶的這兩個相機。
可能他們的拍攝節奏不能特別快。
然後我也不能很輕鬆地說。
隨時的切換他們或者隨便能快門。
這就導致我其實拍的照片。
也沒有想像中應該有的那麼多。
我就記得那兩台相機還挺重的。
然後你那一次去的時候。
全城還背了一個挺專業的那種攝影包。
就是特別像一個攝影名工。
然後在意大利街頭遊蕩。
反正非常的不優雅。
而且其實那一次是我們第二次去意大利了。
其實我還真的對你挺有意見的。
我記得我們其實第一次去的時候。
帶了一個特別輕的一個小位單。
然後我們還帶了非常輕的一個三角架。
然後那一次我們其實反而拍了很多。
特別好的自拍的這種和風景。
什麼小教堂一起合影的這種照片。
然後當然第二次你帶了兩台特別好的相機。
我反而我現在就是完全關於第二次的意大利旅行的照片。
我都沒有記憶
就好像沒有留存
這我記得我們有一次在克里馬吃飯。
就是那一張照片還是手機的自拍。
總之真的就是你帶了兩台特別好的相機。
但是沒有一張好的照片留下來。
確實我覺得大家可能聽上去覺得這個事情反邏輯。
但它就這麼真實的發生了。
我在出發之前也並沒有想到。
最終我會迎來這麼一個結局。
我最終的結局就是我數碼拍的也不多。
我的膠片拍的也不多。
因為過重的負擔以及這兩套拍攝之間需要不停切換的想法。
都讓我可能有點未受未絞的。
但其實我到了意大利那個場景裡。
我又什麼都新鮮可能什麼都想拍。
那我又不知道為什麼就沒有什麼都去拍。
這個時候其實是一個比較大的問題。
所以關於相機帶重了這件事。
我也有一個失敗的旅行經歷和大家分享。
其實我記得就是我們去意大利的同一年。
然後我是年底和同事一起去了江之島。
然後我帶了那個同樣的索尼的那一套全化服備單。
你知道在日本你這一邊逛。
就必然會買很多東西。
我身上的東西就越來越重。
然後以至於我就不得不求助於我的男同事幫我背相機。
因為實在是太沉了。
雖然說可能那次我們一起出去玩。
還是給大家拍了比較滿意的照片。
但是我覺得就是反正以我的體力來講。
那個相機從那次之後我再也不在旅行中帶那個相機了。
因為實在是太痛苦了。
其實說到這裡我覺得有的時候。
尤其對女生來講吧？
你如果帶了特別重的相機。
就是你的同行的無論是男同事男朋友或者你的老爸。
他們可能都不得不成為你的射柱。
然後要幫你承擔一下這個相機的重量的問題。
其實還是有點我覺得還是很抱歉的。
尤其你那次去江之島。
因為想挑鏡頭素質最好的鏡頭袋。
所以你帶了一顆很沉重的菜絲的51.4。
我記得那個鏡頭再加上那個機身。
甭管那個機身它較為單。
那沉起來真的是非常的痛苦。
且它的體積真的一點也不微了。
對我覺得這個可能真的就是對於。
一開始非常喜歡攝影且。
確實擁有了一些攝影技術的人來講的一個。
怎麼說呢一個陷阱。
就是你特別容易說我想出去玩的時候。
就要顯得我自己會拍照。
然後顯得我有這台相機。
是這種心理在作祟你懂嗎。
確實你說平時這些相機都在放燒箱裡吃虧。
平時拿這個相機拍照呢？
在普通的日常裡也不會顯得它特別的好。
但是你想如果你帶了最好的鏡頭。
你帶了最好的相機去了一個最美的風景。
那一定會有一個完美的照片。
我相信大多數人一定是和我們一樣。
都在這個思維上上過這個檔。
就是把相機帶得太沉重這件事。
真的是會讓你的旅行充滿了壓力。
反正自從將知道之後玩。
我就再也不帶這種規模的相機出去玩了。
那我覺得講完了把相機帶重了這一點之後呢？
我覺得還會陷入到一個點。
就是說你這個相機帶的有點貴重。
就是帶貴了
我再分享一個我的失敗經歷吧？
就是前兩年去巴黎嘛？
一開始就是覺得去巴黎。
我就是想好好拍照那麼漂亮的街道建築。
我還有光影
然後我當時就燒得慌。
我就帶了這個萊卡的M11。
但是到了這個巴黎之後。
就發現我在這個治安真的是令人看憂。
然後我長居在巴黎的姐妹也一直在警告。
我說你拿著那麼貴的相機出門。
真的是膽子太肥了。
然後且我們在巴黎的時候。
確實經常就是比如說在地鐵上。
就會碰到一些黑哥。
然後就過來就是與你對視。
想要與你交流
如果稍微晚一點在街上走。
就會有大哥像你飛穩你知道嗎。
就是反正那個整個氛圍確實就非常的緊張。
非常的不安全
記得反正也是個冬天。
我就經常要把這個相機裹在我的大衣裡面。
我就很怕有當地的小偷大哥。
然後這個不小心看到了萊卡。
所以後來就是其實大多數時間。
我都不敢把這台相機帶出門。
你敢想像嗎
等於說我這M11就是帶了個寂寞。
但是我還全程我都得保護著它。
我都得還要為它騰出一塊地兒嘛？
所以這個壓力可能比那個沉重感還要可怕。
所以我覺得剛才聽完我們講重相機。
立馬想出萊卡這個答案的朋友。
在這個時候也可以先冷靜一下。
因為萊卡雖然是體積小一些輕易點點的相機裡。
光學素質有很好的。
但是所有人包括巴黎的小偷。
義大利的黑幫
還有歐洲各地流暫的難民。
他們一定也都知道。
它又小巧又貴
難道不是最好的下手對象嗎。
有說到萊卡嗎
因為萊卡真的拍攝節奏非常好。
這個可以之後單講。
如果在比如說家裡。
或者就是你生活的範圍經常使用它的時候。
你就會覺得它是一個完美的相機。
出去玩的時候你就特想帶著這個相機。
因為它成像質量好。
就是完美
你想去越好的地方。
你越想帶著萊卡
然後我關於萊卡
我還有另外一個失敗的案例。
其實還就是發生在上個月。
因為我們在東京的時候就非常喜歡去高尾山爬山。
當時就說不行
我這個天氣這麼好。
我必須要帶一個好點相機。
我得好好拍拍照
當時就想試一個新角。
我就必須拿萊卡的M6。
但是當爬高尾山的時候。
我就上山和下山其實都非常的瘋。
我就選了它最難的線路。
一個6號線一個3號線。
就反正都是全程需要用登山杖的。
很多的路其實還是挺難走的。
然後我就特別的蠢。
大家可以想像
我背了一登山包
然後我手裡是兩個登山杖。
我脖子上還掛了一萊卡。
就算我突然碰到一個我特想拍攝下來的一個。
而且是覺得非常適合交片的這樣的一個景象的時候。
也非常的尷尬
我就得手腕的上掛著我這登山杖。
然後拿起我金貴的M6。
然後跟著瞄辦地
然後而且尤其是下山的時候。
因為那個路還挺崎嶇的。
因為我的重心其實是要保護我的萊卡。
所以就非常的危險。
我覺得因為我是那種。
寧願自己磕了碰了。
我也不想自己相機。
有一定點的損傷
我又想到了一次
我舍身舊萊卡的一個故事。
就有一次去浦東美術館看展。
當時我身上掛了一個Q3。
然後不知道怎麼回事。
就過馬路的時候
我就背一個東西
辦了一下
我就整個人就跪在地上。
知道嗎
雖然我人跪在地上。
但是我手奔奔地接住了我的萊卡。
它好法無常
但是我的兩個膝蓋都腫。
所以就是你帶萊卡。
就是非常貴重的相機出去玩的時候。
真的很要命
你要為了保護它
然後要付出很多
甚至可能要以身擋栽。
在這一點上
其實我覺得可能大家很多時候。
會忘記一些長頸裡的細節。
比如敬雅剛才說的。
那天去高尾山
我也是脖子撿到掛了一個相機。
雖然沒有萊卡那麼貴。
但是登山杖在你不停地掛在手上。
然後你身體轉來轉去的時候。
相機怎麼招都有很大的概率。
去刻到登山杖上
就算擠不壞它
但是去滑出去到痕。
或者蹭掉點漆
也是一個讓人非常心疼的事情。
這個時候其實我是無比的理解。
為什麼想奧林巴斯。
想賓德
他們造這種有三防功能的單反的時候。
都用的是這個聚合物材料。
那東西真的跟登山杖刻在一起的時候。
一是它更接視點
二是你也確實沒那麼心疼。
你哪怕把它丟在地上。
可能它滾兩下
你也不用去像這個守門員救求一樣的。
去救它
整體來說
在一個比較危險的環境下。
比較複雜的環境下。
一台貴相機給你的壓力還是非常大的。
真的我們在爬高尾山的時候。
平面也經常會遇到一些。
同樣在上山或下山的日本人。
他們真的身上
就不論是妹妹還是爺爺。
經常掛著奧林巴斯。
我那個時候我一點都不覺得。
我身上的M6香聞。
你知道嗎
我就羨慕他們
我覺得待會兒到總結片的時候。
我們公布正確答案。
一定要好好給大家講一講。
為什麼奧林巴斯現在還能這麼堅挺的。
有這麼大的用戶群。
那麼下一個方向是。
鏡頭或者說相機帶的太專了。
這個事兒是我覺得很多很喜歡。
研究器材的朋友也容易犯的一個問題。
以我為例
我有一次正在嘗試中華服機身。
加一周鏡頭的這麼一個奇怪的組合。
然後在家裡待久了。
說走咱出去玩一下。
結果就帶著一個一周鏡頭。
去了蘇州的原林
去之前我腦子裡想的特別清楚。
說你帶一周鏡頭去一個建築漂亮的地方。
這怎麼可能錯呢？
是吧？
你去拍這個原林場景一定是很舒適的。
但是就是這種想當然的心態害了自己。
因為你要去拿一周拍東西。
其實最後還是要上架子。
還是要多次拍攝
才可能拍出一個很好的狀態。
手持拍攝和你隨便拿個鏡頭拍。
差距也沒那麼大
但是讓我很痛苦的就是那天正好趕上下雨。
江南水鄉煙雨蒙龍。
我在一個特別漂亮的古典原林裡走著。
但我只有一顆一周鏡頭。
雖然我有一個特別好的機身。
但那個時候人整個是有一點絕望的。
我想拍的這個東西。
我始終拍不出一個特別好的角度。
我當時就感覺自己不像一個攝影師。
像一個學建築的苦哈哈搞側會的工人了。
我覺得這個感覺是怎麼說呢？
讓我非常難忘的
那自此之後呢？
我就確實對於帶一種特別專的鏡頭。
不再有一種過度的迷信了。
對我覺得確實深度的這種攝影愛好者。
特別容易在出去玩的時候。
就是把這個相機什麼設備給帶過於專業了。
這種情況下
其實也會影響到你的同行人。
你就想那天你在留言裡。
跟那比和跟那瞄跟那對準這一周。
那對於我來講
我就是在旁邊等著你啊？
對吧？
那可能我們的整個遊園或者遊玩的這個節奏都被打亂了。
然後其實我自己想像也經常是這樣。
如果我在出門旅行的時候。
我突然對某一個事物非常感興趣。
我可能真的得在那拍好久好久。
這個你說這和我媽非得要在一棵樹下。
然後揮揚著她的絲巾。
或者跟一個花跟那擺拍有什麼區別呢？
對嗎
就是將心匹心
就可能我們的父母跟那擺拍的時候。
我們也會很煩
但是如果我們跟那就是對著一個什麼特好的風光。
或者一個鳥
或者是一個什麼建築。
跟那沒了的拍的時候。
跟我們一起同情的人也會很煩。
也會很痛苦
所以大家就可以看到。
哪怕像憲哥這樣人際很旺的明星。
也是要走到冤壇打鳥的老法師團隊中。
才能找到一種攝影的快樂。
我覺得這也是一種怎麼說團隊攝影。
團體攝影旅行
可能依然非常火爆的一個原因吧？
對
但他這個其實我覺得還是在以攝影為目標的。
好
那讓我們拉回正題。
我們依然還有關於這個旅遊中拍照翻車的故事。
這個就是來自於我們去年去賴湖內海的時候。
想著都到賴湖內海了。
都在日本了
肯定拿膠片拍嘛？
然後那個時候呢？
又整好手頭在擺弄一堆的半格機。
然後我還特意的把一個半格機買回來試了一下。
又拿去保養了
我自己又拍了一卷。
覺得沒有問題
我就把這個半格機交給靜雅說。
你看這個可可哀哀很古典的發條機。
銀閃閃的還會發出這種滋滋的叫聲。
真的非常好玩
你可以在這次的旅行中放心的用它。
然後我只能對各位說。
閉雷呀？
閉雷
那反正就是這相機。
我奉勸大家對於自己。
反正沒親手使用過的這個相機。
不要把它放在你非常重要的旅行的場景中去。
開啟它的第一次的使用。
就非常危險
反正我那一次非常開心的拍了兩卷。
半格的照片72×2。
140多張
沒有一張是拍好
因為它的這個發條。
不知道為什麼是玄學還是什麼。
我人品的問題
到我手裡這東西它就不爭議了。
就是整個快門全都沒打開。
我後來又去查了一下原因。
是因為我手勁按的可能比較大。
所以它快門在我手裡試的那一卷是正常的。
但是到你這只要稍微按的溫柔一點。
它快門的故障概率就會飆升。
我覺得這也是老相機會出怪問題的一個。
怎麼說大家平時不知道。
但確實存在的很慘痛的一個經歷。
對呀但是我完全不知道。
它會有這樣的一個體驗上的一個差別。
你知道嗎
因為我對於這台相機的認知。
是來源於長子亞美。
不知道大家有沒有看過那個間諜國家家。
第二季的片尾曲的那個MV。
它裡面就是長子亞美在擺弄的。
這個半格的發調機。
就是我用的那個發調機。
我就覺得這個不就是我們姐妹用的嗎。
那怎麼會有什麼手勁的問題呢？
然後所以真的大家一定要慎重。
一定要避雷
像剛才給大家講了我們這麼多的失敗經驗。
其實我們也有認真的反思。
就是說在選相機的時候。
肯定還是要先把旅行的這個場景往前放一放。
或者說起碼在心中旅行和拍照。
要有一個絕對的先後次序之分。
這樣就能更輕鬆或者說更少出錯的把相機選好。
因為所有人都是嘛？
你只要出去玩
你就會非常的興奮。
能量也會非常的足。
其實你就要提前想清楚。
你想把你的能量分配給旅行更多。
還是想分配給攝影更多。
然後去做好這個權衡。
我覺得確實啊？
就是肯定很多很多人。
他還是說要更側重旅行一點的。
但是我順手我還要帶一台相機。
那不如我們就先從這個視角。
來給大家一些
這麼說我們痛定思痛的一些建議吧？
我覺得這個建議肯定是血淚教訓。
非常的有價值
但是不構成任何的購買參考。
請大家如果沒有這個相機的時候。
一定要千萬的慎重要想一想。
要不要因為我們的建議購買它。
聽眾朋友們
如果你們也有特別好的經驗的建議。
也歡迎在評論區
咱們一起來交流和討論。
那麼就來講一講
我們心中現在覺得比較好的。
算是建議答案是什麼樣子的。
基於我們剛才的那個失敗經驗。
我們可以大概總結一下。
就是我們的失敗經驗分成幾類嗎。
那就是帶重了帶貴了帶專業了。
而且我們還想一邊玩一邊試個新相機。
或者新膠卷
那是不是就是更好的一種方式。
是應該反過來
就是說我帶輕的我帶便宜的。
我帶不那麼專業
或者說基礎一點的機型。
以及就是說我不要去做過多的嘗試。
我尋求一種穩定
當然我覺得就是說帶輕的。
然後帶便宜的帶可靠的。
絕對是最好的一個通解通法。
但是以免有朋友
可能想要一些更個性化的答案。
所以我又分了幾個比較細一點的場景。
然後依據我們的經驗提出建議。
我覺得可能會形成一個更多樣的參考給大家。
然後那麼首先來說。
我覺得現在最常見的一個場景。
我遠稱之為City Walk。
無論你平時是去一個沒去過的街區。
同城的地方遊玩
還是你想換一個城市去看看。
或者說你要出國去很遠的地方。
看這種很陌生的風景。
我覺得如果你大多數時候。
是要跟這種人文景觀跟城市打交道的。
那它就都是一種City Walk。
它擁有的是同一類的答案。
那這個答案就是要相機盡量的小。
然後盡量的自動化。
可能在這個場景裡卡片機。
這種東西會更佔優勢一點。
有沒有稍微推薦一點的。
比如說系列可以給大家參考一下呢？
我覺得在這個場景裡。
小這個方面可能要多花一點心思。
可能像卡片機系列。
或者說類似於GR這個體積的相機。
其實現在在我心中是一個首選。
因為在城市裡面如果相機太明顯。
一個是招小偷
另外一個也是會太引人注目。
讓大家覺得你有一種太強的侵入感了。
那你可能拍到的場景也就不那麼自然。
還有就是真的小相機背起來實在是太方便了。
我覺得大家可以試想一下。
如果你要在意大利的街頭走上一天。
去看很多很漂亮的景點。
那這個時候你有一台能揣在褲兜裡。
或者放在上一兜裡的相機。
一定比一個你要背出來一塊的相機要輕鬆很多。
就是小相機好像也有被偷的風險。
那就是在小相機的基礎上。
你再把它弄得便宜一點。
或者你去找一台橙色不太好的相機。
讓人看不出它能值錢就可以了。
那其實就是便宜
就是你不心疼
那第二個場景我覺得也是之前提到過。
也是現在開始流行起來的。
就是去自然風光的旅行。
這個包括了你去登山也好。
或者說徒步也好
或者說你要享受一個走進原始森林的快感。
那我覺得像這個場景。
其實它有一個比較隱藏的特性。
大家可能不注意
就是說你的行動路線是比較固定的。
但是你需要拍的東西可能會離你比較遠。
因為大家想一下
無論你登山也好
徒步也好
其實線路相比於你所經過的地區而言。
往往都是宅小姐固定的。
你需要拍的這個東西離你可能有很遠的距離。
但要不就是山太陡了。
你過不去
或者說你過去了會消耗太多的體力。
影響你整個的形成。
那這個時候其實那種大變焦頭。
就是一個特別重要的配置。
我覺得可以說是在這個場景下。
帶相機的一個很重要的方針。
所以這個時候就要有請我們的奧林巴斯。
真的在山上
我覺得大家多走幾回就能理解。
為什麼那麼多爺爺奶奶。
以及專業的這個野生景觀。
然後風光景觀的攝影師。
會選擇奧林巴斯和松下的這種。
特別小底的相機這個系列。
因為真的是你可能首先重量上。
相同的焦段能清出一兩公斤。
這已經是一個很重的重量了。
然後另外奧林巴斯這種公司。
自己也知道自己的相機大多數被在惡劣環境中使用。
所以它好一點的產品線都會有一個。
比如說防水防塵
防摔的這麼一種三防功能。
這個時候在山上
你可以更多的把精力花在照顧自己。
而不是照顧相機身上。
我覺得這一點來說。
我是終於誤懂了
為什麼奧林巴斯現在的產品線是這個樣子的。
那除了奧林巴斯還有其他的備選方案嗎。
我覺得也有一類特別不被大家重視的相機。
就是三防相機
如果你擁有這麼一台相機。
現在像李光和奧林巴斯做的。
他是做成卡片機這麼一個大小。
然後但是他可以直接扔進十幾二十米的水深裡。
待很久都不會進水。
像這種相機你可能除了去戶外探險燈山的時候用。
你還可以在海邊的時候或者潛水的過程中用。
其實也是一個很自然系旅行所搭配的相機。
如果覺得三防有點太誇張了。
你只是普普通通的燈一下山。
我覺得還有另外一類可能大家平時會看不太起的相機。
就是橋式相機
它的體積大概是比單反小一圈。
但是它的變焦範圍可能是一個20級。
然後到1000毫米等效的這麼一個焦距。
它有大幾十倍的光學變焦。
這類橋式相機一般我現在在國內看到的。
都是爺爺奶奶會用它。
但是在自然的這個場景裡。
我覺得老年人的選擇往往是非常有智慧的一個東西。
對我不知道大家有沒有親手的握持過橋式相機。
真的很輕巧
我就有一次在友多巴西試了一下松下的橋式相機。
真的超級小
超級可愛
我覺得而且變焦我超級遠。
我覺得甚至是可以什麼演唱會都可以拉起來的這種鏡頭。
反正我覺得非常的輕巧。
而且非常適合女生。
對尤其你拿它去拍飛機。
拍月亮
然後拍微距這個鏡頭和小底。
都會給你一個特別好的支持。
可能很多這種老一輩的攝影師。
爺爺奶奶伴的
他們用了一輩子各種各樣很沉的複雜的相機。
到最後很多人可能就會選橋式相機。
比較有實力一點的。
他可能會去選一個來卡的。
所以我覺得真的橋式相機也是一個一直被忽視的相機選擇。
然後還有就是我們因為最近經常登山。
然後就發現其實你在山裡尤其是土布的時候。
經常其實光線還挺暗的。
然後如果出現了陽光。
才往往也是那種光比很強的一種情況。
你可能以為你所見到的都是綠色的大自然。
但實際上當他在背光的情況下的時候。
其實還是一種非常暗淡的顏色。
然後如果你想用膠片去呈現這個畫面的時候。
其實往往會獲得很大的造點。
就反正很難達到預期。
我覺得就是山裡的那個色彩。
其實不太容易被膠片所記錄下來。
對其實大家現在在社交媒體上看到的那種自然風光。
特別漂亮的膠片也都是在那種開闊的地形裡排出來的。
如果你確定自己要登山或者要進森林。
這個時候光線的變化也會容易避到劇烈。
因為你可能走到有舒芬裡漏陽光的時候。
有這個口墨雷斃的時候。
那光比可能會大得可怕。
再往前走兩步
你的曝光條件有一下變了很多。
對於膠片來說肯定是不太友好的。
那這個時候其實數碼相機這種能鎖建基所得。
然後你能提前預覽好曝光效果。
是一個比較不錯的選擇。
起碼你先拿數碼多拍一拍。
然後再像上天宴老師一樣。
架著大拓伏進森林裡拍。
我覺得才會是一個比較好的選擇。
或者如果說你就非想去拍膠片的話。
那其實可以像這個完美的日子裡面。
口墨雷斃的拍攝一樣。
你可以用這種對比比較強烈的黑白膠卷去拍。
那記錄下來的更多的還是光影。
那色彩的部分可能就是要省略掉了。
好那麼說完了自然這個場景。
我覺得下一個場景也是很多人會有的。
它雖然不是這種環境上的改變。
但是我覺得是一個拍攝對象上的東西。
那就是你可能會和家人朋友一塊出去旅行。
這個旅行是一種聚會式的旅行。
大家更多的會把時間放在和身邊的很重要的人。
去享受一個共處的時間。
然後是久別重逢也好。
或者說是一家人去換一個環境。
然後拋下日常的這種工作生活的壓力。
單獨的相處一下也好。
其實在這個場景裡。
我覺得也是要更氣心的選擇一個正確一點的相機。
那像我比較推薦的就是大家戴數碼相機。
然後以及戴這個可以即時成像的相機。
因為在這個場景裡拍焦片實在是一個太慢了的事情。
我覺得像這種相聚在一起的回憶。
然後你想即時的有一張所有人都滿意的照片。
然後去確認一下數碼相機在這個時候會有一個不可磨滅的優勢。
而且就是用相機拍照的時候會感覺更正式一點。
如果大家用手機加焦片的這個組合的話。
可能多少還是會顯得儀式感不太夠。
大家對這份回憶缺少一個用相機生活它的過程。
我覺得用手機最大的一個問題就是。
我跟我媽出去玩的時候。
我特怕她用她的手機拍我。
尤其是說這個景色好。
這個好看你卻跟她合影。
我特怕因為手機的反正她的手機是怎樣。
就是她的手機就是算法過重了。
以至於這個照片就濕針你知道嗎。
就無論是我的臉還是那個風景。
那個藍天那個花它全部都是濕針的。
就是它和我所看到的世界是不一樣的。
那我怎麼能把一個濕針的東西作為紀念留下來呢？
對我覺得是她手機的問題。
是我改給她換手機了。
不是手機攝影的問題好吧？
那我覺得還有一類相機。
我就是前一陣比較火熱的拍立德。
像富士這幾年的新品粒已經出現了。
這個數碼和膠片混合這個混凍車型的拍立德了。
我其實是覺得這類相機在聚會的時候。
是一個特別好的東西。
因為拍立德如果你想去拍合影照片。
然後還讓美人有一張的話。
那其實你整個拍攝花費比較多的時間。
你可能首先要浪費膠片和時間在曝光上。
然後你調好了曝光之後。
其實大家的拍照性質可能就會有點下降了。
畢竟我們的朋友和家人。
它不可能是專業的模特兒或者說演員。
能在鏡頭前維持一個特別長時間的好狀態。
那像這種混凍拍立德對我來說。
就是一個特別好的一個很安心的方案。
就是我可以把拍攝和打印分開。
然後但是我又可以很快速的打印出一個。
不是打印基礎的
是一個拍得像紙的東西。
這東西也會讓當時在場的人非常興奮。
因為大多數就是我覺得家人和朋友是不會挑你這個拍立德。
到底是什麼樣的
他只知道哇你現場印給了我一張我們剛剛的合影。
這個東西真的很能讓我記住今天的這一刻。
我也是覺得在這個場景下。
這類產品是不錯的一個選擇。
那我覺得其實在這個場景裡。
另外一個特別好的東西。
我覺得推薦給大家。
就是一個輕便小巧的三角架。
像我原來是有一隻比較古老的祖傳下來的。
可能七八十年代日本製的。
他折疊起來之後只有大概30公分的大小。
但是他架起來大概有一個1米1。
1米2左右的高度。
然後還帶一個小小的算是兩軸雲台。
然後所以像這個三角架。
其實可以架住我大多數的小一點的相機。
或者說可以換鏡頭相機。
我要給他配一個小小的套頭。
它都是還OK的
那其實這個小三角架也是幫我和靜雅。
在這種兩人的旅行裡拍出了很多的好看的合影。
比如我們在意大利的時候。
想跟一個漂亮的小教堂合影。
我不用再去等一個路過的本地人。
然後還要再跟他溝通一番等等的。
我也當然不用擔心在這個場景裡。
會有一些雕民衝出來搶我的相機。
那麼同時就小三角架在大家拍合影的時候。
也是一個非常好的。
能幫你確定拍攝節奏和構圖的東西。
也不至於說你要犧牲一個。
拍照技術最好的人一直站在相機的後面。
或者你要賭運氣說這個餐廳的服務員到底拍照拍得好不好。
對總之就是愛人神器吧我覺得。
但是大家一定要注意這個三角架還是要買質量好的。
就是質量不太好的。
你上面放一個稍微重點的相機。
那就車毀人亡
那我覺得來總結一下這個場景。
就真的是跟家人朋友出去旅行。
更重要的是能把合影拍好。
或者說有一個很好的分享照片的氛圍。
那在這個時候可能相機本身也不那麼的重要。
更多的是你能讓這個相機在這個社交場景裡。
有一個比較好的發揮。
所以其實就是說和家人朋友在一起的時候。
可能儀式感還是挺重要的。
對吧就比如說用拍立德。
然後圖出來一張照片。
那大家一定覺得很好玩。
然後你用數碼
儀式它的後期的調整空間還是挺大的。
且它沒有那麼實真。
然後同時如果這個相機它有一個比較好的圖傳功能。
你就可以非常快速的無論是分享給你的朋友。
還是發朋友圈其實都是更加方便的。
在我這裡其實有一個小推薦。
就是蘋果的手機是有一個功能的。
就是它叫共享相簿。
它是可以說好友之間共同建立一個這樣的一個相冊的。
就是電子的相冊
然後但是可能是要求大家都用的是蘋果手機。
它好像是可以用iCloud還是就是發個短信怎麼招的。
就所有人拍的這個照片就可以每個人在自己的手機上。
往這個相簿裡面去上傳照片。
然後且只要你這個成員都還在這個相簿裡的時候。
你就可以永久性的去查看這個相冊裡面的照片。
那我覺得其實現在大多數的手機。
可能都已經在開始提供這種服務了。
大家也可以根據自己具體的設備型號。
然後去看一下
我覺得這個雲端共享相冊的方式也是挺好的。
我覺得在日常的這個旅遊場景裡。
還有一個算是比較bug的場景。
它算是在選相機的自由度上比較高的。
那就是自駕旅行
因為你可以同時攜帶很多東西在車上。
所以可能你在這個場景下。
反而是有條件多帶一些相機。
或者帶一些奇怪的也好。
或者重一點的相機。
或者你多帶幾個鏡頭。
那這個時候我反倒覺得。
不用太擔心具體的相機怎麼選。
而是要有一個合理的搭配就可以了。
我們聊了這麼多
那現在來做一個總結吧？
那如果比如說對於很多朋友來講。
可能現在沒有一個明確的說相機的一個選擇的方向。
然後但是我可能未來有很多很多的這種場景。
我都要出去玩
但我還是想選一個。
就是說稍微通用一點的相機。
我們能不能給出一個大致的建議呢？
我覺得這個問題真的提得非常好。
也可能是一個隱藏的很核心的。
所有人都在問的問題。
那我給出的建議也是很有自信的。
就是說你去買現在還在售的。
但是大概是一兩代之前的入門一點的。
就比如說半畫幅這個APS-C畫幅上。
官方給出的這個套機。
那我覺得一般這個選擇是又便宜。
但是其實功能又非常的夠用。
然後又有著很好的應用性可高性保修。
你也不用擔心說它會有任何的麻煩。
那你買新的也可以。
你買舊的也可以
市面上會有很多很多的選擇給出來。
我覺得這種相機在這種問題面前。
絕對是一個最好的解答。
嗯是的
我覺得今天我們這一期錄得非常開心。
因為就是回顧了很多有關於玩的故事。
然後同時也在開始構思新的旅程。
那在這個過程中
確實相機是我們非常重要的夥伴。
其實我因為踩了很多很多坑。
大家也都聽出來了。
然後我現在有一個心得分享給大家。
就是可能每一次出去玩。
嗯那確實旅行的這個過程是最為重要的。
或者說它是首要的地位。
我沒有辦法說
保證自己一定能在這個旅行的目的地中。
拍出一個我自己特別滿意的。
或是什麼絕美的照片。
然後讓我一生難忘。
對吧？
我現在可能會這樣就是說。
我去一個地方
我更像是在看景
我尤其是第一次抵達了一個地方的時候。
我就把它當做是一種看景。
再一次去抵達這個目的地的時候呢？
那你可能就可以變成一個。
更加以攝影為目標的一個狀態了。
那我覺得像靜雅剛才說的這個場景。
其實還是帶有著專業人士。
或者說攝影師的一個思路在裡面的。
其實是可以幫助更多對攝影有指念的朋友。
很好的區隔開自己的旅行和攝影。
那對我來說
我想站在另外一個方面。
就是可能有那80%大多數的人。
大家還是會因為很尊重一次旅行。
只有一次的旅行怎麼拍好這個照片嘛？
那我覺得我的建議就是。
大家不要被裹寫
不要被他人的聲音所裹寫。
因為其實能拍出你心目中理想照片的。
只有你自己
無論你是看了多少。
勸你帶什麼相機
怎麼用相機的建議。
還是你看了那些很專業的旅拍博主。
在這些旅遊目的地產出的精緻美麗的照片。
其實那都是一種屬於這個時代的幻想。
一種信息留下內卷的產物。
它可能會讓大家被這些信息所裹寫。
而失去了這種享受自己旅行的心情。
我覺得這個真的就特別像是學區房雞碗的感覺。
就是說我看到有人上北達清華了。
那我的孩子也得努力的去上北達清華。
然後我就在給他買這房。
我就在給他上這學。
其實有點像這種思維。
那這其實都是現代社會。
然後包括我們所處的這種社交媒體。
所帶來的這種壓力。
真的我覺得有些時候挺離譜的。
就是關於這個旅行的照片。
最後還有一個故事想分享給大家。
就是我有一個好閨蜜。
然後他當時在英國留學。
然後他當時在英國的時候有一個前男友。
這前男友畢業了
就是說你能不能幫我拍一套。
這個倫敦各大景點的照片。
就是什麼大本中
什麼各種各樣的地方。
然後結果我這個朋友。
他也不是什麼專業攝影師。
然後就反正給這男生拍的就不好。
你知道嗎
然後這男生就覺得自己這一年留學。
都沒有留下一個特別好的記憶。
然後就跟我這姐妹就撕了。
就分手了
而且鬧得特別的嚴重。
然後他自己也特別不開心。
然後我這姐妹就特別無語。
所以我覺得可能還是希望大家能夠玩得開心吧？
當你學會去感受旅途。
感受生活的時候
我覺得這也是可以拍出一個好照片的一個開始。
我覺得大家在出門旅行之前。
可以去看看那個白日夢想家。
看看攝影師在雪山上面對雪暴。
不按快門時候的那種心情。
可能是更容易理解。
更容易放鬆下來享受好自己的拍攝。
享受好自己出片率非常低。
但是能留下非常美好回憶的這種感覺。
我們其實還是想為大家展現一下。
我們從彩坑到反思。
再到總結出一些可供參考的經驗的。
這麼樣的一個過程。
然後也希望大家能夠有一些啟發吧？
能夠根據自己現有的相機的情況。
還有自己的譬如說預算和計劃等等。
能夠找到一個合適的相機搭檔。
那我覺得如果大家聽完我們的這期節目。
感覺有收穫的話
也非常歡迎你分享。
然後點贊收藏
這樣我們就可以知道。
我們這期相機閒聊節目。
到底有沒有真正的幫助到大家。
好的讓我們來到美其比歐的這個彩蛋環節。
那麼今天的彩蛋呢？
是來和大家講一下。
我們兩個為下一場旅程準備了什麼相機。
那既然先來吧？
因為我們4月份其實是要去京都國際攝影節的。
關於這個攝影節的內容。
我們在之後也會盡快的和大家來分享。
所以就是因為我們要去做那個新幹線嘛？
然後也不想買那個指定期想省錢。
所以我們就不想帶太多行李。
那相機一定要選擇一個非常輕的。
我最近非常至愛的一台相機。
真的我就是還要再一次安利它。
就是這個Camp Snap。
我特別慶幸就是
我是在特朗普提高關稅之前買到這台相機。
我覺得這世界上還有比它更輕的相機嗎。
都反正握在手裡
應該也就30到50克的感覺吧？
然後隨便放在兜裡非常的輕鬆。
然後只要是光照OK的時候。
它就可以任意的拍攝。
而且非常的有焦味。
那個彩造完全不噁心。
就沒有科技很活的味道。
我覺得它確實符合了我們前面所書裡的這些。
對於出遊旅行的相機的基本的原則吧？
對吧？
輕便宜
沒那麼專業對吧？
我也不用去
而且它也挺穩定的。
連根線就能立刻看圖了。
同時我現在當然就是不會只帶一台相機。
我還是追求一種搭配的感覺。
所以我大概率還是會帶著我的M6。
因為去年真的在京都。
然後趕上了櫻花季。
然後用這個M6拍出了非常非常好看的照片。
所以就是今年可能還是想繼續吧？
靜雅的這個組合一看就屬於那種銀很大。
就是拿M6這種135的終極解決方案。
和CAMSNAP這種最簡單的完美解決方案搭配。
對
因為我就還是想出片。
就是誰不想在櫻花季的京都。
然後拍到幾張漂亮的膠片呢？
是不是
抱著這種想法
我的組合跟它可能有點差不多。
我的數碼這一段選擇的是。
我前兩天剛從家裡翻出來的祖傳卡片機。
就很奇怪
可能我們家上一輩人對攝影也是有隱的。
在我們家不僅翻出過卡片機。
還翻出過膠片機
還翻出過膠片單反。
還翻出過放大機
那麼這個卡片機我還挺喜歡的是。
富士最後那幾代CCD傳感器。
然後它等於會有一個比較神奇的Sensor的排列。
它好像是鑽石型還是零型的。
所以我這回打算去京都試一下。
看看它究竟能有一個什麼樣的效果。
對
我覺得那個相機非常適合拍夜鷹。
因為它的閃光燈什麼的。
反正各種能力非常齊全。
微距啥啥都有
到時候我們拍夜鷹就靠你這個小卡片了。
對然後它那個相機裡面甚至有花卉模式的。
我覺得就那個年代的卡片機會有很細的花卉模式。
煙火模式
然後自然的這個人像模式。
模型模式
總之就是它會按長項去給你分相機的功能。
不用再自己想太多。
這點也是一個特別好的體驗。
所以你就只帶這一台嗎。
我可能根據我隱大不大。
會再考慮要不要再帶一個類似於中華服。
但是辯寫的這個膠片機來看一下。
因為確實去年我帶那個GF670在京都。
拍這個670的膠片還是有一張特別好看的。
那個好看的程度吧？
可能會驅使著我今年再帶中華服膠片去一下京都。
嗯是的
不過最近膠片又漲價了。
唉所以就是給膠片配一個自己非常喜歡的小小的數碼。
真的變得越來越重要了。
那我們這一期就聊到這裡。
那麼以上就是本期節目的所有內容。
非常感謝大家可以收聽到最後。
也歡迎大家積極的在評論區裡和我們聊一聊。
你對這期內容的想法有沒有一些更好的建議提供給大家。
好那讓我們下期再見再見。
我們是愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛。
愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛的愛。